[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
happy taco tuesday
it is day two
of judge brown jackson's
nomination
committee hearing
in the judiciary committee
in the senate
confirmation hearing excuse me
confirmation hearing in the senate day
two and of course we have the uh [ __ ]
bag gop
republicans doing what they always do
hating women that's like they're
that's what they do best
is hate women they don't really do
anything better than that i mean there's
a few things they do better than but
hating women is one of their pastimes
it has been for a long long time lindsey
graham
is complaining to judge brown jackson
about
trump's
exit plan from afghanistan
i don't i don't know if he's trying to
blame her for the detainees from gitmo
becoming part of the afghan government
as trump made that deal with him
or i'm not sure what the [ __ ] he's
talking about
like it's her fault that trump made the
deal with the taliban
to make sure that those
gitmo detainees that were released with
several deals that were made in exchange
for american soldiers
i don't know i don't know i don't know
if if if he's blaming her he really is
complaining about it though he's
definitely complaining about trump's
exit plan from afghanistan
and the gitmo detainees that were in the
taliban now becoming part of the afghan
government he's really [ __ ] upset
about that
i'm not sure why he's talking to her
about it i don't know why he didn't um
call
uh
the trump administration
to the judiciary uh committee and why he
hasn't you know subpoenaed them to come
testify
but then that that's
that's neither here or there i guess i
guess um
he also blamed her for defending
defending a gitmo detainee
because she was detaining a war criminal
like you know here's the thing is that
in this country
rather and he he's trying to make the
case that the people in gitmo um don't
deserve
uh the representation
because it's war
it's war
and in this country needs to have the
debate about gitmo
we've had tried to have it several times
several times
but
it just
it's not it's not working out
the way that the country wanted it
and it really does send a shitty signal
to the rest of the world when lindsey
graham
sits to question
the confirmation of a supreme court
justice
and challenges her work to defend
a a client
as an attorney not not as a judge
just the same way josh hawley and uh
judge brown jackson destroys
absolutely destroys josh holly today
we'll we'll probably get to that clip as
well
um destroys josh hawley's nonsense
about how did the sentencing
that she gave
to
sexual predators
josh holly i said yesterday and i still
believe this he is absolutely [ __ ]
obsessed
obsessed
obsessed
with porn
and in the case judge brown jackson he's
obsessed with child porn
obsessed with it he can't get it out of
his his skull
i don't know maybe there's maybe there's
one of josh hawley's laptops we could
find somewhere in a repair shop i'm just
saying uh there's a lot of folks here
this morning carter's here gail is here
good morning lisa
good morning all uh let's hear we have
kathy is here
uh uh
carter's here again
gail says she's she's early for a change
robin is here of course good morning
robin
and the [ __ ] fam and the midas mighty
is here
uh debbie from salt lake we have forest
from facebook we have we have people
watching on facebook you guys know that
we're we're live every single morning
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter twitch but yesterday as
episode 100 commenced we were on midas
touch facebook page live
it's really live like as you hear my
voice i'm speaking into the microphone
mj is here good morning mj she says hi
[ __ ] fan
fam
we're all here oh we have martin here
our marine here for from facebook
now we have emily
hello emily she says second day couldn't
wait for you to go live we're glad to
have you emily
we're glad to have you crystal's here
she's talking about the sparklers that
must be hal
hal um hal sparks
so she's a sparkler is as well
good good morning good morning crystal
from facebook
we have a lot of we have a lot of folks
here uh
david is here he said josh hawley is
projecting hey i know i don't think
that's uh too far off
i don't think that's too far off uh josh
hawley being a projectionist i mean he
is a republican
he is a [ __ ] republican so i mean
like that that's part of the i think
that's like a prerequisite for the job
like they're like oh so you want to run
for office on the republican ticket
are you willing to project all your mis
misdeeds and your misnomers
and your faults on to the democratic
party are you willing to do that
mr white ball sack dude everyone likes
the white ball sack i said republican
wrinkled ball sacks yesterday and
everyone liked that
for some reason that's what they are
that's what they are did you see chuck
grassley
he he looks like a wrinkly old
republican
ball sack with eyeballs
i'm just saying just saying and lindsey
graham added to the list today
uh deanna is here from facebook
uh cali says lindsey graham is a traitor
[Laughter]
rick from facebook uh good morning rick
good morning
and uh jeff says first time listening in
good morning jeff from facebook everyone
and a lot of people over there on
facebook don't forget if you're on
facebook go subscribe to the youtube
channel
uh you can just go to
thetonymichaels.com
or you can go to you can go to youtube
and type in the tony michaels podcast
and you'll find our our youtube page
that way if you miss any of it you can
always go over to youtube and watch and
if you're on twitter you facebookers you
books of facers
if you're on twitter follow us at tony
michael's pod we do a bonehead of the
week poll every single week
every single week we do a bonehead of
the week poll over on twitter so if you
want to participate and there's going to
be a lot of boneheads this week a lot of
them already have a whole stack of
boneheads to pick from
here's here's what happens to all the
people on facebook that have not
yet seen what bonehead of the week is we
do a poll with three boneheads
three [ __ ] boneheads you know we
already got lindsey graham josh holly
chuck grassley in the running here but
we select three boneheads we posted on a
poll on twitter you get to vote you get
to practice voting it's a good way to
practice voting you get to vote every
single week on who you want to be the
bonehead of the week and then on fridays
in the second hour because we do two
hours a day here
every single weekday monday through
friday 11
eastern
or excuse me 12 eastern 11 central
right here on youtube twitter twitch and
now on the mind as touch facebook page
but on friday the second hour we do the
bonehead of the week we break down what
your vote was who won and we also have
the alpha cuck of the week and the
dishonorable mention because here's what
happens with the bonehead thing we do
the poll and we have the three people
well there's always more [ __ ]
boneheads than the poll can handle and
by the time we get to friday there's
already someone in the news saying
something even more boneheaded than the
three that we put on the pole so we come
up with this honorable mention and then
uh it just so happened then we came up
with alphacock of the week so
we end up with five contestants that we
talk about on the bonehead of the week
segment and that's friday in the second
hour of the show
so don't forget to again subscribe to
the youtube channel go over there and
like and give a thumbs up if you're on
facebook give a thumbs up give a comment
down below
we want you to to stay with us every
single day there's a ton of comments
coming in
a ton of comments coming in i think i
think i'm going to be the only one today
gabe gabe is a little busy today he's
got a lot to edit we're going to have an
interview this week um
you guys have heard of bad brad berkwit
we're going to be releasing that
interview this week we talked to bad
brad berkwit yesterday
really really good discussion we had
yesterday uh brad brad has uh
a very a very very very cool clip
of his of his dad
that we're gonna show on that interview
and you're really going to see um why
bad brad has the attitude that he has
so check that out this week we'll have
that interview ready for you
in a few days
so we're really uh we're we're working
on that we got a few comments here it
looks like we got uh sparklers here um
i'd love to have hal on the show you
guys your sparklers would you guys would
you guys like to see hal sparks come on
nitoni michael's pot guest i'd love to
have uh hal on uh to pick hal's brain uh
hal is one
one of the funniest political
commentators out there uh so we we would
we would love to have hal on you should
you should you should float it to hal
maybe i'll maybe i'll
send out a message see if he wants to
come on the show we'll do it live
we'll bring hal on live i think hal
could do live he does live anyways when
his stream it live
hal likes to do that
uh
so
we got a lot to go through in the [ __ ]
list today you guys know we go through
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
um there's a lot of footage that's
already started to
make its way onto twitter and clips
about lindsey graham and chuck grassley
uh durbin and then
judge brown jackson
starts destroying these white nut sacks
um i've sent these republican white nut
sacks
of senators that they have
um there's a few other things trending
uh stormy daniels is trending
because donald trump thinks he he won i
don't i don't understand um we'll we'll
run through what that means
uh let's see what what else do we have
on the tweety tweets and attorney trends
today uh other than the biggest thing is
the confirmation hearing of
judge brown jackson we also had i guess
kid rock was on tucker carlson oh wow
boy
big [ __ ] news i'm sure i'm sure
he said some really riveting [ __ ]
i'm sure
that's exactly what he did
what the [ __ ] kid rock on tucker
carlson as in the words of george carlin
[ __ ] tucker tucker sucks and we also
have some news uh about navalny it looks
like um
they sentenced navali navalny to nine
years in prison i i guess
i guess putin thinks he's going to be
around nine more years i don't know
i don't know
you know
guantanamo bay is trending because
lindsey graham is still butt hurt
about the detainees that were released
from gitmo
and
and he's he's really upset he's really
[ __ ] upset that the trump
administration made the deal with the
taliban to take over afghanistan
and that all those detainees that were
released are now are now in the afghan
government that was that was a trump
deal dumb [ __ ]
that was a trump deal
biden didn't make that deal i don't know
what he's trying to get at here he's
he's questioning the wrong [ __ ]
he's complaining to judge brown jackson
about gitmo
which
judge brown jackson has nothing to do
with gitmo not a goddamn
thing not a goddamn thing
uh let's see here what else do we have
training oh new world order that's right
we had our title judge brown jackson in
the new world order i almost forgot
we have to go through the clip
of the the leader of our cabal
ah this is so funny this is so funny
they they think that sleepy joe biden
who can't even put two sentences
together he comes out and he says new
world order all of a sudden us
us us joe biden cult members who have
flags and hats and we go to we go to joe
biden rallies and we oh we we sit for
four days in the tent in a field in
alabama to wait for joe biden to show up
and [ __ ] on us
what the [ __ ] are you people talking
about
george soros joe biden in the new world
or you people really are [ __ ]
delusional
not one person i can't i can't even tell
you
i've never met i've never met one person
in real life that voted for joe biden
that would go sit in a field for four
[ __ ] days in the tent to wait for him
to show up to speak
because they know joe biden's in
washington at the white house doing his
[ __ ] job getting up in the morning
putting his [ __ ] shoes on doing the
thing that presidents do you know
presidenting and [ __ ]
not like the last [ __ ] that was
so concerned about what was on tv that
day what's on tv
oh let's watch some tv let's see what
the television tells me to do
and they're [ __ ] they're in their
trump hats and their trump capes and
their trump boots they probably have
trump underwear trump tattoos they got
the trump flags all over their trump
trucks
they go and they they tent out but they
camp for four days for that [ __ ]
to show up in a field somewhere in the
goddamn south because nowhere else is he
[ __ ] welcome in this country
like a bunch of [ __ ] sheep and they
even fence them in like sheep at these
[ __ ] nazi rallies that they have
and somehow somehow joe biden he says
he says the word just the words new
world order and they [ __ ] lose their
[ __ ]
absolutely [ __ ] lose their [ __ ] so
we're definitely going to talk about
that [ __ ] today i can't wait to make fun
of the ku and on trt voodoo trump cult
the let's go brandon nazis yes let's
[ __ ] drag them through the mud
that's what we do here on the tony
michaels podcast uh let's let's uh so
i don't know if we're gonna have guests
today or not we're still waiting to see
um
uh
who who were uh
who we may or may not have on it's kind
of it's kind of fluid at this point
this is this is what live shows are
about though if you guys are out there
listening and you're new listeners
that's what this is about it's a live
show two hours every single day
you guys get to listen in and the best
part about the live show is even if you
miss a little bit or you're here or
there we're gonna have rants uh you know
i i rant the whole two hours almost and
then we have guests on
the greatest part about it is it's over
on youtube it's recorded you can always
re-listen or it's on twitch or on
facebook
you guys will be able to re-listen to
this the best part is if you don't want
to watch my beautiful face if you just
want to hear my beautiful voice
you can always download it it's on all
the directories even the best boycotted
ones
spotify apple google any directory that
you want
we've been posting the pod link on the
facebook page but if you go to
thetonymichaels.com
you can find all the podcast links there
you can go find
in any directory that you download your
podcast in just just search the tony
michaels podcast that [ __ ] will come up
it will come up
and we're a proudest and we're proud to
be in association with midas touch again
we're live
every single weekday
youtube twitter twitch and now
the midas touch facebook page we've got
a lot of we got a lot of folks from the
uh from the facebook page over here uh
cali is here
she says oh my god i [ __ ] love you i
love you too
i'm beginning to like this facebook
thing i wasn't sure how it would like it
but the the comments come in pretty easy
i wasn't sure how that was gonna work so
i'm glad uh you guys are joining us over
there on facebook
uh we always we always have fun here
for two hours
on the tony michaels podcast
um we have all kinds of stuff that
happens
every single day
every single day and we go through the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends
and right now i think we need to go
watch some clips
of judge brown jackson destroying josh
hawley and lindsey graham crying about
how
white people are so mistreated let's
start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome to the shitless roundup here on
the tony michaels podcast as you know we
go through the tweety tweets and trendy
trends of the day it's really just the
news
like you know like like the trending
news what everyone's [ __ ] talking
about that's that's what we do that's
what twitter is it's a goddamn feed of
what everyone's talking about whether
it's irrelevant or not who knows but we
talk about polit politics and social
issues every once in a while we bleed
into other things you know like
hollywood but most the time that has to
do with social issues or politics but we
give the political commentary of the
left
in a way in a way that the [ __ ] fam
loves
and that that's been the mantra that
i've had for a long time [ __ ] them [ __ ]
them
so anyone new who has not uh who has not
heard the content yet that is the
attitude that we have
if you miss the opening
um we
we give we give you the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends with some gusto
and then in a way that i think is missed
by the left
you know what happens a lot of times
with these left-wing
shows or left-wing commentators is they
try to they try to beat you up with a
big encyclopedia book or facts or
statistics [ __ ] that [ __ ] if you got a
good argument
if you got a good [ __ ] argument
against something or for something or
whatever the hell it is
if you got a good argument it's a decent
[ __ ] argument you don't need a whole
goddamn book of facts a whole goddamn
book of statistics to throw at someone
that's where we lose some of these folks
i'm telling you
gas prices for example joe biden does
not have a gas price button on his desk
it doesn't exist
there's your argument
gasoline companies the petroleum
companies are gouging you you dumb
[ __ ]
there you go crude is going down and
gasoline stays up
who picks the gas prices joe biden
doesn't have a gas price button it
doesn't exist no president does
they don't have like a [ __ ] knob on
their desk i mean you know here's the
thing if they do have a gasoline button
though here's my suggestion
in this country if we if we want to talk
about policies like gasoline prices
right because these people are bitching
about filling up their [ __ ] gas
guzzling trucks number one that's
ridiculous but if they want to still
complain and that the president has
control over gas prices i'm fine with
that
i'm fine with the prezi united states
having control over gas prices i'm good
with that here's what i'll tell you
though what the president also should
have control over is ammo prices how
about that how about that if the if the
president united states is going to have
a new world order and he's gonna control
the gas prices maybe they should control
the [ __ ] ammo prices too huh
that's i'd say that's pretty good that's
a pretty good [ __ ] policy
there you go any anytime anyone [ __ ]
says the president states says hey they
have control he's urged
joe biden raised the price of gasoline
you say well that's good that's great
that's great you're blaming joe biden
for the price of gasoline he has control
over it we're admitting that he's
starting a new world order he's the
dictator he's the king
let's have him raise the ammo prices too
i don't know i'm just saying like i
don't know the thousand bucks a box
maybe five thousand bucks a box
just saying
maybe maybe he should raise the price of
of
of bullets
as chris rock would say
all right let's go through the tweet
tweets and train trends let's stop
[ __ ] around here okay uh we we're
gonna start on the timeline here got a
few things i want to show you uh scott
mcfarlane
and mcfarlane
uh scott if you don't follow scott you
gotta go follow scott uh he keeps you up
to speed on all the january 6 updates
out of dc and the courts and he also
keeps you updated around the country as
these uh
the news breaks inside these other
courtrooms he said arraignment of uh
enrique tario is now beginning stand by
the criminal investigation into proud
boys leader enrique tario is going ahead
of
11am arraignment prosecutors notified
court
has executed more search warrants and
seized more devices
contemporaneously with the arrest of
tario now more defendants expected to
per the feds here's the thing
this case is a federal conspiracy case
um that is the indictments were handed
by down by the grand jury i'm no [ __ ]
lawyer i'm no [ __ ] lawyer but
and i do know one thing you do not [ __ ]
with federal prosecutors uh when it
comes to them having your balls in a
ringer especially when the word
conspiracy gets tossed around in
indictments um what you're probably
gonna see here and my guess is this is
my this is my
this is this is my prediction
of the proud boys the oath keepers all
this [ __ ] um they're gonna have several
superseding indictments um in these
cases for this for this edition that
they committed we seen a couple weeks
ago and we even played it on this show
uh
about
the the meeting that stuart rhodes the
founder of the oath keepers
who is also charged with seditious
conspiracy and
uh enrique tario the the subject of this
tweet here
we've seen the meeting in a in a parking
garage
um a documentary crew was apparently
documenting their
their treason they wanted to have a
treason movie apparently
document all the treason they said
document it all get it all the treason
on film we want to make sure we have it
on film that way when they
they go to prosecute us they have all
the evidence
of
treason i guess i don't know i [ __ ] i
don't know how the [ __ ] am i supposed to
tell what these idiots are thinking
we've had dakota adams which is stewart
rhodes estranged son on this show
several times i think three hopefully
we'll have him on as soon as we know a
little more about this or enrique tario
case and some of this oath keepers
updates
hopefully we'll have him him on again
but dakota
dakota has given us a good insight into
the mindset
of not just militia but the oath keepers
and stewart road specifically
and they thought they were gonna get
away with this that's why they were
documenting it
it would never [ __ ] record evidence
of of treason if they didn't have to
why would you [ __ ] provide evidence
to the courts and the feds
why why would you do that well because
they thought they were gonna get away
with it
they thought they were gonna get away
with it um so stay up to speed with uh
scott go follow scott on on
on twitter
um here here actually here here's more
to the thread he's updated uh since i
posted this defense lawyer has asked to
push tario's arraignment back a week
uh attorneys want more time another
accused proud boy including dom
zola
who alleged smashed open capital window
uh will still be arraigned tario is in
pre-trial jail
so he's further extending his stay uh
the the this probably enrique tario
january six case has all the hallmarks
of a case that'll be delayed and
postponed deep into this year
case is growing more phones more search
warrants possibly more defendants and
tario himself wants more time meanwhile
other proud boy defendants are pleading
not guilty right now uh dominic or dom
pizzola i think that's how you name it
say it um new york has been in pre-child
attention for more than a year
and his uh perspective trial date
appears
listen to slide further um so
scat is kind of reporting
kind of what i said um stewart rhodes is
also looking to change his trial date
they're all going to change their trial
date they're going to oh they're going
to train change their trial trial date
hodges here says laptop laptop laptop
yeah maybe
maybe maybe they got laptops from from
enrique tario
rico tario's laptop what's on that
laptop
probably emails
did you guys hear that hunter biden
actually owns a laptop can you [ __ ]
imagine
hunter biden owning a laptop that's
[ __ ] ridiculous get out of here with
that [ __ ] okay um here's a clip of the
contanji brown jackson but we're going
to get back to that
i'm going to get back to this
and give it its due time but we're going
to go down the feed here just a bit
[Music]
oh here here here this is another
thing from scott i don't mean to this
isn't like a scott show
but uh you got to see this uh uh the
january 6 defending coy griffin of new
mexico this is a guy that i think he's
the i think the group is called cowboys
for trump
cowboys for trump i think that's the
name of the group like literally that's
the name of it
you know you got the oath keepers you
got the proud boys
he had all these domestic terrorist
groups
uh latinos for trump blacks for trump
you know all these all these trump
groups
and this guy this griffin i believe is
the uh
the leader of the cowboys for trump
and he came out of the courtroom today
and he's apparently not a fan of scott
mcfarland but listen to what what listen
to what this guy said he's very
confident one more day but
i feel like uh it was a good day um you
know the trial went very well uh yeah
the honorable judge trevor mcfadden is
an extremely fair judge and he's just
looking at the law and the prosecution's
presenting their case that's how court
works that's how court works this is the
way our justice system is supposed to
work that's how court works we still
have confidence in our justice system
today and we're looking for a big win
whenever we get get through with this
deal tomorrow commissioner you stand
here on so this guy i don't know if
you've seen clips of this [ __ ]
this griffin here but this guy's been
been since since it started
since it started
uh
uh
this griffin
has done a few went to a few trump-like
events and kind of [ __ ] blamed trump
trump
kind of blamed trump for for like not
pardoning people and you know he didn't
do what he was supposed to do this guy's
kind of pissed off at trump believe it
or not
this guy's kind of pissed off that trump
didn't do what he said he was going to
do he didn't he didn't follow through
with the coup
i mean because if trump really would
have followed through with the queue the
idea is is that
these [ __ ] idiots wouldn't have
gotten trouble they wouldn't be in court
they wouldn't have been arrested you
know because if if the trump really
would have [ __ ] all over the
constitution and tore it up and throw it
in the trash with january 6 with the
cheeto dust kangaroo coup
well
then these [ __ ] idiots wouldn't be in
the trouble that they're in if the coup
at the cheeto dust kangaroo coup would
have been a success
if the john eastman memo and the
powerpoint presentation would have they
would have followed through with it
oh yeah everyone's saying honorable uh
judge he's calling him an honorable yeah
he's kissing his ass you're right fency
he is definitely kissing his ass he's an
ass kisser well that's what most these
[ __ ] people were doing anyways dakota
adams has said as much about stuart
rhodes
stuart rhodes was so worried about being
convicted for [ __ ] that happened at the
bundy ranch are indicted excuse me
stuart rhodes is so [ __ ] scared of
being indicted with [ __ ] that happened
at the bundy ranch that's why he got on
the trump train that's why he was
willing to commit try to commit a cheeto
dust kangaroo coo
in conspiracy with the proud boys
enrique tario and um and others
and here you have this guy cowboys of
trump now now watch this this is the the
end here
because what what happens is scott asked
him a question
right
scott asked him a question here and he
gets really pissed off at scott
on trial you have regrets now about
january 6 being a part of it no i don't
i don't live a life of regrets
but um i also know that you're one of
the biggest hit jobs out there and it's
unfortunate that i don't know if you
report back to the cia or the fbi or
what intel agency
oh so what he's saying is reporter
reporter scott mcfarlane who has been
who has been reporting on this stuff
for
for over a year right he's been
reporting on this [ __ ] for way over a
year every single defendant right
and and i i don't know i i i almost i
almost got the sense that he regrets
this [ __ ] griffin cowboy guy this
this [ __ ] idiot in this hat
i really i really think that this guy
regrets not saying the word sorrows and
you see it when this uh you see this you
see this guy standing here in this
leather vest that has this obnoxious
phone case in his pocket you see that
there he's got this obnoxious phone
thing in his spot who carries their
[ __ ] phone in their vest pocket
come on grandpa what get with it you
carry it in your [ __ ] back pocket of
your jeans for crying out loud
[ __ ] me i mean you can set it there in
your pocket when you're sitting down
when you're out walking around walking
the streets you don't carry your [ __ ]
cell phone and you're what the [ __ ] are
you doing everyone knows this this is
common knowledge
why do we have to tell these people
these things you don't carry your phone
in your goddamn vest pocket you carry it
in your [ __ ] jean pocket if you can
like the back pocket
that's where you carry the son of a
[ __ ] everyone knows that don't it
doesn't everyone know that
this guy doesn't but but i i really do
think that griffin here the guy in the
cowboy hat that is
i really
i really do think i really do think he
regrets not saying the words george
soros
out loud he says cia who you working for
but listen watch watch here what happens
when this uh i don't i don't know if
it's a relative of griffin or just a
friend here this guy in this leather
vest this older gentleman here in this
leather vest he doesn't know that you're
not supposed to put the [ __ ] cell
phone in your back pocket he puts it up
in his leather vest pocket well watch
watch what happens here
uh
scott continues the question what agency
are you with sir
what agency are you with sir
what agency are you with sir what the
[ __ ] why why do these people listen
this is so [ __ ] boneheaded here's
another example of of of how the left
misses these simple [ __ ] arguments
why how in the [ __ ] do these people
think that trump was the president in
charge of the cia the fbi the executive
branch
all right the department of justice
and they think all of a sudden that
they're just they they just get rid of
all those people and have all new people
when there's a new president do these
people really think that all the
government workers go away
and then they get all new ones like oh
they fire all the republicans get all
the new democrats this is why trump
really [ __ ] failed
at being a republican president to be
honest with you this is one of the
reasons this is one of the things and
it's going to show
in the years to come
and republicans are going to regret this
a lot for having this buffoon as their
president because here's what happens
when you have a president united states
in a certain party the whole idea the
idea of having control of the executive
branch for four years or eight is ideal
is because you get to you get to embed
people who are you know
sort of
on the scale of your ideology inside the
government
like that's the whole purpose is to
build up the the bureaucracy or the
institutions as it is
with people who are sympathetic to your
ideology
trump did not do that everyone thinks he
did but he did not he destroyed agencies
he gutted agencies he gutted
institutions in this country
only leaving institutions open and ripe
for joe biden and the democrats and
congress and the legislator to pack full
people who are
sympathetic to her ideology this is how
government works folks
like this is not [ __ ] rocket science
i watched this for four years as he
gutted the state department
all those people who left the state
department who may have been
sympathetic to the republican ideology
at one time that george w bush
put in the state department gone
gone guess who's gonna fill it
you think you think george w bush is
gonna fill those spots now oh joe
biden's gonna build those spots at the
state department
people who joe biden appointed are gonna
fill those spots over at the state
department
think about that for a second i'm not
saying it was a good thing that that
donald trump left our government hanging
from a from a thread
but the fact of the matter is
is that he did his party a really bad
disservice by not packing the [ __ ]
institutions in the government full of a
bunch of uh of trumpers i mean we still
have some trumpers lingering about you
know like the the joy [ __ ]
that [ __ ] and a few others that
just can't be shuffled out the door but
that's the point don't you see that's
the point is when you elect because
elections have consequences when you
elect a president in the united states
or they're a republican or democrat you
get to pack those things but these
idiots here believe
believe that scott mcfarlane who is a
journalist
who has been reporting on not just their
crimes but their their conspiratorial
and their their other insurrectionists
that were along with them their crimes
they think he's part of the cia
they think he's part of the fbi or some
agency what the [ __ ] does that mean
this is all queuing on [ __ ] and we're
gonna get into this a little later about
the new world order but let's let's
finish up here let's listen to what this
bonehead says you know i'm not a fan of
you you know yeah he's not a fan you can
come after me whenever we have jeffy
reports
all these other pedophiles in america
that are abused
there you
there you go
there you go that's the josh holly go to
that's the q anon go to
if you can't make a good [ __ ]
argument against a journalist who's just
reporting what the [ __ ] the truth and
the facts are coming out of the court
if you can't
if you can't handle that the first thing
you do is say the word pedophile
first thing you do i mean i would i
again i would say that this guy probably
regrets not saying the word soros or
hunter biden's laptop
what a [ __ ] idiot what a [ __ ]
idiot
to think that scott mcfarlane
is not doing proper reporting on the
january six insurrection it
he is doing a service for the american
people rather you believe that the
insurrectionists were traitors or you
think they were patriots which they are
not
but even if you think that the
insurrections are patriots why even if
you're a right winger why wouldn't you
follow scott's account scott's account
is giving the bare facts of the court as
it happens almost live a lot of times
i mean i'm sure it's scott mcfarlane you
know he seems like he's a smart dude so
i would imagine that he has a half a
brain and he can manage to put together
an opinion about these [ __ ] idiots
and about the country and about the
insurrection but scott truly doesn't let
that show through his tweets and his
reporting
because he not just does tweets he does
uh videos too on updates on some of
these things
but this guy is truly upset at scott
[ __ ] hate scott
because you know scott makes him look
bad with things like
facts
using children and you're so focused on
january
he's you're so focused on [ __ ]
pedophiles
why are you doing new mexico to face
charges
you're more obsessed
you don't have regrets about being part
of january i i don't know i'm i'm good
right now we're going to have a big win
tomorrow
and for you it's too bad that you're not
more concerned about pedophiles in
america than you are people that crossed
over into onto the capitol
i would say that griffin here he maybe
we should find a laptop at a repair shop
for him too not just josh hawley
but him as well thank you scott for your
reporting you are true american
you are a true member of the free press
and i appreciate your twitter feed
every single day every single report
that you put out don't stop
don't stop
uh this guy's a [ __ ] okay let's get
back to the feed here
um jim jordan tweeted this morning and
amy one of our favorite amy lynn
here if i can get this thing to work
there we go amy lynn says don't forget
well let's read let's read
let's read jim i don't report sex crimes
jordans
uh tweet here
jim i don't report sex crimes jordan
says
don't forget what democrats did the
brett kavanaugh oh my god
this is more of this [ __ ] lindsey
graham [ __ ] right
this crying about how white people get
mistreated i'm dead serious
crying about brett kavanaugh and hey me
cody barrett they were so mistreated
they asked them questions about their
faith and how they would make decisions
based on their faith
yeah of course we did because you're
you're [ __ ] you hide behind your
faith to be a
bigot jim i don't report sex crimes
jordan
[ __ ] lindsey graham you
sons of [ __ ] you dirty bastards you
dirty [ __ ] bastards listen these
[ __ ] hide behind their [ __ ]
faith all the time to be [ __ ] bigots
that's exactly what brett kavanaugh what
amy coney barrett and neil gorsuch do
and lindsey graham has the gull this
morning to say well these white people
were questioned about their about hiding
behind their faith of being bigots and
it makes us look like bigots and then i
have to sit here and ask a black woman
about her faith and that makes me look
like a bigot well
if it walks like a duck it quacks like a
duck it must be a [ __ ] duck
lindsey graham and jim i don't report
sex crimes jordan
oh by the way that last [ __ ]
that last cowboy we had on that griffin
why is he so concerned about scott
mcfarland when he could be concerned
about jim i don't report sex crimes
jordan and matt peto
gets
if you're worried about [ __ ]
pedophiles maybe you should be worried
about [ __ ] pedophiles and your own
goddamn ilk
griffin amy lin says here i'll calm down
just a bit amy
amy's one of our favorite here
on the tony michaels podcast as we're
rounding up the tweety tweets on the
trinity trends amy says don't forget
what brett kavanaugh did
to christine blasey ford yes
you [ __ ] idiot jim jordan walked
right into that didn't you dumb [ __ ]
yeah he's [ __ ] these white nut sacks
that's what these are these white nut
sacks we gotta stop this stuff okay
oh oh the stormy daniels case the stormy
daniels case
uh trump's really upset
that uh
that no one will talk about how he beat
stormy daniels and stormy daniels owes
him money because she misfiled
i don't know some kind of briefing or
some [ __ ]
which i'm sure will be appealed
what i said because this statement here
this [ __ ] statement from the [ __ ]
grabber which i don't normally post this
[ __ ]
and someone was saying in the comment
feed stop posting what he's saying [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
i always tell you guys don't look away
and i'll post the important trump [ __ ]
as it comes
as it comes we will report this [ __ ] and
this is important and the reason why it
and it doesn't seem important right like
the stormy daniels case the michael
cohen the michael avenatti you know saga
all this [ __ ] that they're trying to
spend it's [ __ ] important and the
reason why it's important is because
they they so easily attack stormy
daniels
because republicans hate [ __ ] women
and they attack women especially like
stormy daniels who are who's a sex
worker who's in pornography it's so easy
for them to attack a woman who's a sex
worker sex work is [ __ ] work
and we as democrats too need to stop
shaming [ __ ] women
that are [ __ ] sex workers it's enough
of that [ __ ] if if stormy daniels wants
to be a porno star let her she could be
in pornography that's her [ __ ]
liberty that's her [ __ ] right that's
her [ __ ] living for crying out loud
and trump and the republicans take
advantage
of that because they ate women they
[ __ ] hate women and i said stormy
daniels shouldn't pay a dime to that
[ __ ] grabbing coward [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him
[ __ ] him
not a goddamn dime she should pay oh
here's a good story you guys seen
yesterday breaking uh in my great state
of missouri the former governor there's
a reason why he's a former governor
because he he duct taped his hairdresser
to a to a treadmill and made her pose
for naked pictures and then use him to
blackmail her that's why
that's why that's the truth eric
greitens can try to run from the truth
he can try to blame his sexual assault
on his hairdresser on mitch mcconnell
all he [ __ ] wants
all he [ __ ] wants but it won't work
it will not work eric greitens what a
piece of [ __ ] i called him a [ __ ] box
twice yesterday because he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] box
at one point felicia reports here at one
point eric greitens made a reference to
the fact
that he had the children and she didn't
while trying to persuade sheena greitens
which is his uh his ex-wife and she's
the one who made the statements
um the allegations about him uh being a
domestic abuser yesterday to delete
emails that she had sent to the family
therapist seeking help according to an
affidavit
and he's a [ __ ] liar he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] box he's a crazy [ __ ] this
guy's off his [ __ ] rocker
listen i'm from missouri i know folks
that were in his administration
that's right
i know people who were in his
administration
and they say
he's a [ __ ] whack-a-doo
and the republican and he blames it on
steve bannon's trader tv i think i might
have that clip yeah it is
here's a trader tv at its with his best
guest i haven't said this yesterday
he predicted this yesterday that he
would go on steve bannon's trader tv i
said it
i knew he would
he loves he loves he loves traders he
loves them
so listen to [ __ ]
well steve the reason why shots are
being fired at us is that i was the
the reason why shots are being fired at
you eric
is because you're a you're a [ __ ]
domestic abuser and you're a rapist
and you're a sexual assaulter that's
what you are and you're a [ __ ] you're
a [ __ ] thief
yeah that's right you steal from your
own veterans charity the list to try to
get yourself elected governor the state
of missouri you're a [ __ ] criminal
you're a crook
is what you are eric
come at me [ __ ]
first guy in the country to come out and
say that when i'm elected to the united
states senate as an america first
senator and they get did you catch that
he's a nazi senator
america first he's a nazi senator he
wants you to know that he's a fascist
an outright fascist he wants you to know
that but i'm voting against mitch
mcconnell
i'm sure mitch mcconnell is so [ __ ]
scared of you i'm sure he's terrified of
you the [ __ ] out of here
well steve the reason why
christ blaming blaming his domestic
abuse allegations on mitch mcconnell is
what the republican accountability
project says here
yeah okay okay eric you got it
got it
it was mitch mcconnell that made me
smack around my wife a little bit it was
mitch mcconnell that made me duct tape
my hairdresser to the treadmill in my
basement and then take naked pictures of
her and use it as blackmail
you son of a [ __ ] mitch mcconnell
listen and the other thing too that he
does is he blames the democrats oh it's
all the left the left is coming after me
you know when he when he's doing this
[ __ ] eric greitens that is when he's
doing this [ __ ] right
when he's when he's when he's [ __ ]
going out there saying who's to blame
when he when he had to resign as
governor because that's the deal they
made we'll either prosecute you or you
resign
and he resigned
as governor
of the state of missouri
he let his governorship go because he
didn't want to be prosecuted that was a
[ __ ] deal they made
he can say whatever the [ __ ] he wants
but listen
aaron greitens is a scumbag
and it was the republicans in missouri
not the [ __ ] democrats if you know
anything about missouri politics at all
you would know that democrats don't even
hardly exist in the government in
missouri as far as the legislator is
concerned and the legislator is the one
that holds the check and balance on the
executive branch in missouri
it was the [ __ ] legislator that did
the investigation into eric greitens
they're the ones that pushed him out
they're the ones that published all
these reports about him duct taping his
hairdresser to a [ __ ] treadmill naked
and taking pictures of her are you
listening what this [ __ ] did
all's i'm waiting for cause trump's
going to endorse him
you wait trump's going to endorse this
[ __ ] absolutely the [ __ ]
grabbing coward is going to endorse
the duct tape bandit here
eric greitens
of course he's going to
jesus christ kimberly guilfoyle donald
trump's whatever she is girlfriend
beyonce whatever they are you know
they're probably going to try to get
married so they don't have to testify
against each other in court
like matt gatz did his wife the point is
this the point is this is that even
kimberly guilfoyle is backing eric
greitens some kind of campaign manager
or some stupid [ __ ]
you know what i'm talking about the best
is yet to come lady the best is yet to
come
that lady
she's somehow been tied into eric
greitens campaign so you of course trump
is gonna [ __ ] back eric greitens the
duct tape bandit the duct tape rapist i
don't know we'll come up with some kind
of [ __ ] nickname for
for eric greitens
speaking of more republican pieces of
[ __ ]
um
robin i think you sent this this is uh
newt gingrich
um talking about uh
kamala harris they they really they
really love to
to to say racist [ __ ] about
about powerful black women they're
absolutely [ __ ] terrified terrified
that black women have power
let's listen to this this wrinkly old
republican nut sack
so we got joe the
cognitive mess as president we got
kamala harris
kind of a disaster unfolding every day
and not far behind them is
uh the our own struggling
cognitive mess that is nancy pelosi so i
don't really have a lot of confidence in
the government right now mr speaker but
maybe i'm wrong you helped me out
well first of all
if you want
a strong reason
to pray for the health of the president
united states
you are reminded again today
that that reason is the vice president
you are such a piece of racist [ __ ] i
can't hardly hear this but thanks robin
for sending it and
again more republican wrinkled old
nutsacks all right let's go to the
tweety tweets and trendy trends we are
54 minutes into the first hour we got a
whole hour left folks
that's right stay with me we're going to
watch a ton of clips here
we're going to watch a ton of clips
on this supreme court i'm sure there's a
ton of them posted by now
that we will keep
we will keep watching uh yeah profin
supply it was the the audio was bad on
the video it was hard for i had it
turned all the way up
it was the audio was really low
so we're gonna move on there um we got a
lot of people from facebook here who are
new today i appreciate that
you guys showing up
and uh listening here every single day
we're going to be we're going to be
streaming on the midas touch facebook
page at noon eastern 11 central every
single weekday monday through friday
youtube twitter twitch and now
the minus touch facebook page now you
can go follow
and subscribe on our youtube channel
just go to thetonymichaels.com
or search the tony michaels podcast when
you go to youtube and you'll find us
make sure to give us a like
over there when you go
you can find all the links all the links
all the socials
all the podcast links if you want to
listen to the podcast on all the the
boycotted even even the best boycotted
directory spotify apple google whatever
directory you will i heart radio
a lot of our listeners listen on apple
if you want to download if you want to
download the the podcast just the audio
you can go do that on all your
directories
just go to thetonymichaels.com and you
will find all the links there and don't
forget if you're on youtube you can do a
super chat now super sticker super chat
don't forget we have that option now
in the youtube chat if you come over and
in chat live in the tubes of you
in the tubes
of you
uh some other stuff that's gonna come
this week uh we're gonna you guys know
we have rachel bitkoffer the political
strategist from strike back we have her
on often to get her um her voice on
messaging she went on charlie kirk's
show
and the other day and there's a link out
there
but she was wearing a shirt fascism
sucks
a lot of people been asking about the
fascism suck shirt
just go to
hats.thetonymichaels.com or go to
thetonymichaels.com
click on the merch store with the
fascism sucks
use the promo code podcast
and get 10 off the entire store your
entire order so go check out
go check out the fascism sucks shirts
over there on the merch store
again rachel was wearing it she was
wearing that shirt during the debate
with charlie kirk i'm not kidding you
she's wearing the shirt fascism sucks
when she was debating charlie kirk and
she slam dunk some uh we're gonna put
some clips out of that uh this week i
think this week or next week we're
waiting on a few things
to manifest there but stick with us with
the second hour we're gonna go to a
short break we will be right back with
the second hour right after these
messages don't go anywhere stay right
with us we'll be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy
by the time we reached dc we was 50
strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob i'm fixing to send you some
more of them doritos you like the red
bag not the lib loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] a [ __ ] [ __ ]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show
[Music]
thanks for hanging with us on the break
there
[Music]
we are working our way into the second
hour of the tony michaels podcast again
every single weekday noon eastern 11
center on youtube twitter twitch and now
on the midas touch facebook page
because we're in association with midas
touch you guys probably follow the
myzellus brothers
on the midas touch media network
with uh lee mcgowan the politics girl
anthony davis the weekend show and five
minute news let's see what else we got
we got the kremlin file we got zoomed in
of course you have the uh d midas touch
podcast with brett jordy and ben and
then you have and then you have uh that
legal af we've had pope hoc do some
pop-ins here of course jordy and brett
have been on the show so has been
but pobac has done some um
some poppins uh the legal af wednesdays
pop joins kfa
hopefully maybe we should have kfa on
the podcast what do you guys think
should i uh should i get kfa
over here on the tony michael's podcast
i think so maybe we'll have her on see
if we can get her to say [ __ ] him
i'd love to see if we could get her to
say welcome
and but with that on wednesdays and i
and so tomorrow um they'll drop lego af
uh the the midweek episode which is with
popak and kfa and then on weekends
they have
legal af on the weekends edition which
is ben mizelis and and michael popock
over there
mj says lee too
are you saying mj are you saying you
want us to have
lee on the show
because i i would love to have lee
mcgowan on the show i get i i i know lee
would probably say [ __ ] him for sure
and crystal says kfa is fabulous
so
yeah maybe maybe we'll have kfa and and
lee mcgowan on the podcast coming up
soon
coming up soon this week we have a great
interview with uh bad brad berkwit we
just got done putting it in the can as
it were we recorded that interview for
all those new listeners out there we do
we do have uh the uh interviews uh try
to do one or two a week
last week was anthony scaramucci the
mooch
you can go watch that on the youtube
channel
uh that interview last week's episode i
believe it's 98
is the episode number with anthony
scaramucci but we've inter interviewed
dakota adams we've interviewed tasha
adams which is stewart rhodes of strange
wife and dakota's mr rhodes estranged
son
we've had a lot of others on we've had
john walsh on misty model
um a lot of guests that i'm
not even remembering at this point we've
had the mizellas brothers on
um
and that that that guy donish he's been
on it's been a lot we've had a lot on so
we'll continue with the guests every
single week well maybe we'll try to
bring you more and more guests we had
walter masterson on
which was a great interview
uh walter is hilarious by the way if
you've seen any of his videos from
[Laughter]
any of his videos from the trump rallies
he's hilarious
some of his last uh videos were from the
trump rally
where they were
um you know they were they were they
were saying putin is the good guy
yeah of course putin's a good guy that's
what trump says trump says he's the good
guy so he must be the good guy
now these people when what do you think
their look on their faces is when they
found find out they're the baddies huh
oh we're the baddies supreme court is
trending at number two still let's let's
refresh here see if it's
there it's knocking down the number
three
by uh hashtag
moneybag mikey and hashtag xbox signings
two sweepstakes
um
important [ __ ] in our country xbox sonic
and moneybag mikey yeah important [ __ ]
important [ __ ] you know not like the
supreme court
that's not important
knock that down the number three america
why do you want the supreme court to be
trending at number one it ain't like the
supreme court is important or nothing
it ain't like what the republicans the
racist [ __ ] that republicans say to
judge brown jackson is important
that we need to know what the racist
[ __ ] they say is
yeah well
we'll do it here on the tony michaels
podcast for sure
number three supreme court let's make
this bigger so we can see this
let's see if that i know there's going
to be a lot of
a lot of clips here let's just go to
some video here um
here's a little clip of
lady g it's from recap molly has
reposted she says it's 2022 and senator
lindsey graham asked this question
during a senate supreme court hearing
this should be riveting let's listen
what faith are you by the way
senator i am um
protestant
okay
non-denominational okay
could you fairly judge a catholic
senator i have a record of i don't
answer to you judging everyone i believe
you can i'm just asking this question
because
how important
is your faith to you
senator personally
my faith is very important
um but as you know
there's no religious test in the
constitution under under article 6
[Laughter]
this this this judge brown jackson is
after my heart
isn't she after yours oh my god
just totally takes lindsey graham's
questions and slam dunks that
[ __ ] in the trash
yes slam dunks it right in the [ __ ]
trash
what an idiot
okay let's see let's see if there's some
more clips here i want to see some clips
of her dunking on some more republican
uh wrinkly old republican nut sacks here
[Music]
do there's gotta be some clips here we
go amy's got one here
let's see what what is this um oh this
is the opening statement from uh judge
jackson yesterday we didn't play any of
the opening statements so maybe i'll
i'll play this opening statement here um
and then we've got uh she's got a thread
here
um
here's um
some more clips so we'll go down amy's
thread here if you guys aren't following
amy girls really rule you probably need
to
very important
very important threads that she post
here is here's uh judge brown jackson's
opening part of our opening statements
yesterday
members of this committee
if i am confirmed i commit to you
that i will work productively
to support and defend the constitution
and this grand experiment of american
democracy that has endured
over these past 246 years
i have been a judge
for nearly a decade now and i take that
responsibility and my duty to be
independent very seriously
i decide cases from a neutral posture
i evaluate the facts
and i interpret and apply the law to the
facts of the case before me without fear
or favor
consistent with my judicial oath
i know that my role as a judge is a
limited one
that the constitution empowers me only
to decide cases and controversies that
are properly presented
and i know that my judicial role is
further constrained
by careful adherence to precedent
now in preparing for these hearings you
may have read some of my more than 570
written decisions and you may have also
noticed that my opinions tend to be on
the long side
that is because i also believe in
transparency
that people should know precisely what i
think
and the basis for my decision
and all of my professional experiences
including my work as a public defender
and as a trial judge
have instilled in me the importance of
having each litigant
know that the judge in their case has
heard them
whether or not their arguments prevail
in court
during this hearing
i hope that you will see
how much i love our country
and
the constitution
and the rights that make us free
i stand on the shoulders of
so many who have come before me
including judge constance baker motley
who was the first african-american woman
to be appointed to the federal bench and
with whom
i share a birthday
and like judge motley
i have dedicated my career
to ensuring that the words engraved on
the front of the supreme court building
equal justice under law
are a reality
and not just an ideal
thank you
for this historic chance
to join the highest court
to work
with brilliant colleagues to inspire
future generations
and to ensure
liberty
and justice
for all
thank you judge jackson uh so there you
hear the some of the opening statements
yesterday of judge
brown jackson
here's the thing
as you watch her opening statements and
you see as she maneuvers her way through
as i put it these republican wrinkly
ball sacks that are these gqp senators
and their stupid [ __ ] questions that
they're going to have for her
as she as she maneuvers her way through
these things you're going to see
something that
is the stark difference between the
parties because we get this [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] all the time where people
are like oh republicans and democrats
they're exact same they're exactly the
same they have the exact same results
it's the exact same [ __ ] you never get
anything different from the democrats
and you get from the republicans they're
all bought and paid for both sides this
both sides that bull [ __ ] [ __ ]
there is no better example in the
difference in the and and the
pro-democracy party which there's only
one pro-democracy party right now in
this country that is the democratic
party
and the fascist party which is the gqp
then the nominees that have been
nominated that have sat before the
senate judiciary committee
katangi brown jackson
amy coney barrett brett kavanaugh that
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] and neil gorsuch
listen
lindsey graham continued to [ __ ] and
[ __ ] and [ __ ] and moan this morning
about how brett kavanaugh and amy coney
barrett they didn't get a fair shot they
didn't get they were questioning about
their faith and they were questioning
about their past and blah blah blah blah
blah that's because brett kavanaugh was
accused of sexual assault you dumb
[ __ ]
that's because amy coney barry uses her
religion to hide her bigotry
it's her [ __ ] excuse to be a goddamn
bigot
and to try to take liberty away from
americans
i don't give a [ __ ] if you want to know
what
katangi brown jackson's religion is
she does not have a history of hiding
her
her wanting to take away liberty from
americans behind a religion she doesn't
do that
she doesn't have sexual domestic or
sexual assault allegations against her
she doesn't
because she
she
she's never done that
if you're wondering if you're trying to
find a [ __ ] difference when you have
some [ __ ] idiot in front of you
trying to say that both parties are the
same
here it is
here it [ __ ] is
the republicans can do nothing but [ __ ]
about how bad their candidates are and
how the democrats had to run through the
and scourge through the absolute garbage
that these candidates supreme court
nominees were
that trump [ __ ] that trump nominated
and they could do nothing
but [ __ ] about those nominees and how
bad they were in judge brown jackson's
hearings
because they're i mean they're they
they have a really rough time a really
rough time
criticizing judge brown jackson for
anything i mean josh hawley tried to i
don't know what he's trying to do
projection that a pedophilia or some
[ __ ]
i don't know i don't know why he's so
[ __ ] obsessed with porn and child
porn in this case
but it's very obvious the difference
between the parties when you see their
nominees for the supreme court
just just to the mere questions that you
can ask these folks
think about it
think about it there's not one
[ __ ] on this senate judiciary
committee that's gonna ask katangi brown
jackson about an event where she
sexually assaulted someone at a party
when they were drunk
there's not a chance in the [ __ ]
world that we're going to watch kataj
katangi brown jackson judge brown
jackson
cry in her beer
we're not
we're not gonna see
one [ __ ] moment where
where a senator has to question this
nominee about her hiding behind her
religion to press her bigotry to take
away liberty from other americans
not gonna happen
they can't ask those questions and the
reason why is because there is a [ __ ]
difference there's a [ __ ] difference
between pro-democracy people in this
country and [ __ ] fascists
there's a [ __ ] difference
and there's also a difference
in paid for supreme court justices of
course they project that [ __ ] onto
contangie brown jackson as well
lindsey graham tried that garbage
yesterday and it didn't stick very
[ __ ] well
the best argument that they have for
2022 is hunter biden's laptop folks
that's the best hope they got
if they think they're going to make
judge brown jackson an issue in the
midterms
let them [ __ ] him
a bunch of morons and again if you come
across some [ __ ] idiot out there who
says both parties are the same here's
your [ __ ] example
slam dunk those [ __ ] in the
trash okay here is um
amy says watch this fantastic
explanation by judge jackson of her
process when undertaking a new case and
how she
endeavors to determine the statuary
meaning of the law now this is a little
this is a little long but again i told
you i wanted to leave enough time um i
think it's i think it's very [ __ ]
important for people to see
how educated black women are in this
country
that's they're they're they're the most
educated demographic in the entire
[ __ ] country
there's a reason for that there's a
goddamn reason why judge brown jackson
is is gonna beat out any [ __ ] any
[ __ ] white dude for the supreme court
justice
seat
and there's going to be a whole line of
black women that are going to beat out a
bunch of [ __ ] even democrats even
white liberal males they're going to
beat them out
the reason why is because black women
women but black women especially in this
country have to work 5 000 times harder
to get where they're at
which means they put all the work in
they put all the experience in
and it shows with judge brown jackson
and it shows in this clip that we're
going to show here
and i think it's important for the
country to see
and to hear
why
why joe biden wanted a black woman on
the supreme court not just maybe i mean
the obvious reason is to make the
supreme court look like the american
public look like america we want the
supreme court don't you want the supreme
court to look like america for [ __ ]
sake but the other reason why is because
katangi brown jackson
is overly qualified overly qualified if
you take the last three [ __ ] nominees
and put them up against katangi brown
jackson she's way overly qualified to be
on this supreme court that we have
bought and paid for right now
way over qualified
and the reason why is because she's
worked she's had to work so goddamn hard
because of who she is
you think neil gorsuch worked as hard
as katangi brown jackson
do you think brett kavanaugh
oh that's a funny [ __ ] joke that
brett kavanaugh worked half as hard
as judge brown jackson get the [ __ ] out
of here with that [ __ ]
again
my personal opinion is and let's expand
the supreme court let's put four more
seats and i'm not opposed to all four
seats going to black women
in this country
maybe clean up the [ __ ] mess that
white men have made let's listen
to the explanation of judge brown
jackson of her process when she
undertakes a new case
let's hear what she has to say judge
jackson there are two issues that came
up
repeatedly yesterday from the other side
of the aisle that i want to address at
the outset
one of them was a question of judicial
philosophy
no one questions
either your
academic
law school credentials
or your service as clerk
and as federal judge
but time and again
you have been asked what is your
judicial philosophy
does it fit into
scalia's originalism
kavanaugh's textualism
is it strict construction is it liberal
is it conservative
lo and behold i've discovered the answer
it turns out that during the course of
your time as a judge you have actually
had written opinions
573 to be exact i think
maybe i'm off by one or two
and they more or less express your view
of the law as the facts are presented to
you in each one of those cases and then
some 12 000 pages from the sentencing
commission transcripts of deliberations
on important issues
for most of us as elected senators
if people asked what what's your
philosophy we'd point to our voting
record
you have a record when it comes to court
decisions and this committee for the
fourth time
is delving into everything that you've
published as a judge and even before
so would you like to comment at the
outset
of those who are looking for a label
what your position is on judicial
philosophy
yes thank you
mr chairman
over the course of my uh almost decade
on the bench
i have developed
a methodology that i use
um
in order to ensure that i am ruling
impartially
and
that i am adhering
to the limits on my
judicial authority
i am acutely aware
that as a judge in our system i have
limited
power
and um i am trying in every case to stay
in my lane
and so what i do um is i essentially
follow three steps the first step is
when i get a case
i
ensure that i am proceeding from a
position of neutrality
um this means that you know you you get
a case and it's about something and it's
submitted by certain parties
i am clearing my mind of any
preconceived notions about how the case
might come out
setting aside any personal views
it's very important that judges rule
without fear or favor
the second step is once i've
cleared the decks so to speak in this
way
i
am able to receive all of the
appropriate inputs
for the case
that is the party's arguments they've
written briefs
sometimes we have a hearing
sometimes we hear from other parties
amiki in a case
and then there's the factual record i am
evaluating all of the facts from various
perspectives
i think my experience all of the various
experiences that i've had really helps
me uh at this stage to see the
perspectives of all of the parties and
to understand their arguments
and then the third step is the
interpretation and application of the
law
to the facts in the case
and this is where i'm really observing
the constraints on my judicial authority
um there are many constraints in
our system importantly because just
judges have limited authority
and so i am first of all looking at my
jurisdiction uh threshold matter in
every federal case is to make sure that
you even have the power to hear the case
um
in evaluating jurisdiction you're
looking at all sorts of things the the
text of a jurisdictional provision for
example precedent related to it
um
if i can get to the merits of the case
if i have jurisdiction
then i am
uh observing the limits on my authority
concerning the questions so if it is a
statute for example or a provision of
the constitution i'm looking at the text
the adherence to text is a constraint on
my authority i'm trying to figure out
what those words mean
as they were intended by the people who
wrote them
so at this point
i'm looking at original
documents i am focusing on the original
public meaning because i'm constrained
to interpret the text
sometimes that's enough
to to resolve the issue in terms of the
merits
judges
also look at history and practice uh at
the time of the the
document was created if it's a statute
i'm looking at congress's purposes
because again i am not
importing my personal views or policy
preferences the entire exercise is about
trying to understand
what
those who created this policy or this
this law intended
i'm also looking at precedent which is a
another constraint on judicial
okay i think i think we get the idea
here
and the biggest difference between
again judge brown jackson
and the [ __ ] republican nominees
uh
amy coney barrett
neil gorsuch and that [ __ ] scumbag
brett kavanaugh
i think i think we can see the
difference
and i think it is a disservice to the
country
to look at this example and say because
i mean here's the thing here's the thing
even republicans are having to ask
katangi brown jackson
about how does the process work
when you're
when you're making a decision as a judge
like that's the questions they have to
ask
they can't ask her did you sexually
assault this person in 1984 at a party
because you were drunk
you were at a drunken frat party
no they can't ask her that [ __ ]
question they can't they want to but
they can't
that's why lindsey graham brings it up
because they want to be able to ask her
that question but god damn it god damn
it you pick those democrats and joe
biden just picked two good nominees to
be on our [ __ ] supreme court that we
can't ask them questions about their
personal character because their
personal character shines through their
experience god damn it
they're pissed
they're [ __ ] pissed that judge brown
jackson is a good decent [ __ ] human
being they're pissed
they're pissed off about it
god damn why can't you just be the
bastard that we nominate we not nominate
a bunch of son of a [ __ ]
to the supreme court the democrats get
to drag them through the mud because
their personal character is [ __ ]
garbage they either hide behind they
hide their bigotry behind their [ __ ]
religion
or their [ __ ]
their sexual assaulters
or they make really dumb [ __ ]
judicial decisions
that seem archaic
because they're a constitutional
originalist the constitution is not a
living document we've seen that [ __ ]
from that old wrinkly republican nut
sack chuck grassley yesterday
reeling on and on and on about how the
constitution isn't a living document
dumb [ __ ] they want to live in
the in the late 18th century that's what
makes america great again
is the late 18th century get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ]
it's not a living document all you
[ __ ] republicans do is [ __ ] about
the first two amendments amendments
changes to the constitution
you dumb [ __ ] and you don't
even know what those two [ __ ]
amendments mean or say in the first
place
and you that's as far as you get
with the amendments anyways there's a
lot more than just the two
but there's a stark difference here
and just the [ __ ] questions that can
be asked she's not responding she's not
responding to dick durbin's question
she's responding to dick durbin pointing
out that josh hawley's a [ __ ] idiot
that's all she's doing is saying yeah
yeah of course i had to [ __ ] sentence
these people it was my job and i have
constraints when i'm a judge
the law constrains me
from certain actions that i can or
cannot take
it's it's it's called equal justice
under the law
and yes is our justice system [ __ ] up
and broken in this country sure there's
a lot of bad things about it a [ __ ]
a ton of horrible things about our
justice system in this country not just
not just the federal justice system but
state system county system city systems
all steeped in systematic racism of
course
of course there is
democracy and justice isn't always
perfect
it isn't
unfortunately
i mean we could strive to try to make it
better and one of the reasons the one of
the ways we do that
is nominate
nominate a person
who is [ __ ] qualified to be a supreme
court justice like judge brown jackson
or really honestly any of the the list
of
of
dozens of black women that were on the
nomination
list that joe biden was considering
and just tells you right there
who's overly qualified to be supreme
court justices
but that's a stark difference in this
country between the two parties and it
ain't got nothing to do with republican
and democrat at this point it doesn't it
just has to do with i don't know decency
decency
donald trump couldn't find three decent
[ __ ] nominees for the supreme court
of the united states well the reason why
is because they were bought and paid for
by the federal society but that's a
whole another goddamn show that's
probably a four-hour show as opposed to
a two-hour show
and we're 28 29 minutes into the second
hour we do not have enough time for that
[ __ ] let's go back to a clip here that
amy has um
when asked about court packing judge uh
jackson uh says she's she agrees
with justice barrett my north star is
the consideration of the proper role of
a judge in our constitutional scheme and
in my view judges should not speak
to political issues
so she's not saying rather she would or
she wouldn't
uh pack the courts what she's saying
here and i'm i'm sure we're he'll hear
it in the clip here
is that that's not a judge's job
it is the legislators job which we have
a legislator they should pack they
should pack the court
they should pack the court right now
right [ __ ] now let's do it [ __ ] them
another issue which has come up to my
surprise and i've spoken to my
republican colleagues about their
fascination with it is the notion of the
composition of the supreme court
which euphemism euphemistically is
referred to as court packing
i have said on the floor and i will
repeat here
uh
there is exactly one living senator who
has effectively changed the size
of the supreme court
that was the republican leader senator
mcconnell
who shrank the court to eight seats for
nearly a year in 2016 when he blocked
president obama's nomination in merrick
garland
now that question on court packing was
posed to amy coney barrett justice in
the court when she appeared before this
committee
she was asked about it
she said and i quote could not opine on
it
and on many other policy issues then
judge barrett said repeatedly she could
not share her views stating and i quote
i will not express a view on a matter of
public policy especially one that is
politically controversial because that
is inconsistent with the judicial role
i do believe we should have rules and
traditions and precedents but we
shouldn't have a separate set of rules
for republican nominees and democratic
nominees
so judge jackson
if a senator were to ask you today about
proposals about changing the current
size of the supreme court what would
your response be
senator i agree with justice barrett in
her um
her response to that question when she
was asked before this committee
again my
north star
is the consideration of
the proper role of a judge in our
constitutional scheme
and in my view judges should not be
speaking in to political issues um and
certainly not a nominee
for uh a position on the supreme court
so i agree with with justice
well she may agree with justice barrett
which i think is probably a good answer
you know this is the answer that the
republicans are looking for in other
words um they can democrats can say well
she gave the [ __ ] same answer as your
nominee dummy um into the packing of the
courts so you accepted that answer why
can't you accept this answer lindsey
graham oh well jamie coney barrett was
treated so unfairly she was asked
questions that that justice brown
jackson won't be asked here's the
question
here's the question lindsay mark it down
you little [ __ ] put it in your [ __ ]
notepad
lady g
uh
here's the thing though i'm not i'm not
a judge i'm not a for nomination i can
make political statements pack those
[ __ ] pack the court you [ __ ]
ain't right i'm all for changing how the
court gets nominees
there's a lot of good ideas out there to
make this less political because i think
i think the less political we make this
process for nominees of supreme court
we're going to get more
people who are qualified to the level of
judge brown jackson here that's what
we're gonna get
we're gonna stop getting amy coney
barrett's and brett kavanaugh's to even
be considered for the supreme court
i think the process should be that the
president united states is the one who
gets to pick the the chief justice we
should do away with how the chief
justice is done now how it's done now is
there's a chief justice seat when when
john roberts leaves that chief justice
seat whoever is the president united
states at that moment gets to pick the
chief justice i think the president
united states should get to pick the
chief justice while they're in their
term of office sure fine why not [ __ ] it
let them have it
but i think also we should have rotating
temporary supreme court justices
that that come from the appellate court
or from district courts
kind of like uh rookies
a rookie system right get them used to
making decisions and we shouldn't have a
certain number on the court that get to
hear every [ __ ] case either
we shouldn't should draw straws that way
there's none of this [ __ ] of this
judge and this judge are gonna make this
decision on every single [ __ ] case
we could pack the courts to 12 15 20 if
we wanted to hell we could have 30
justices on the supreme court in that
case where they draw straws the only
straw that isn't drawn is the chief
justice and that's where the president
gets his nomination
and the senate gets to
do their due diligence and making sure
that person can be the chief justice
but the courts
take their cues from the appellate
courts those judges come up from the
appellate courts in the district courts
to help make decisions on the supreme
court with the permanent justices
and those permanent justices are then
appointed by the current members of the
supreme court
and they can do their little [ __ ]
stupid little dance that they do here in
the judiciary committee and the senate
where they [ __ ] vet them and and
you know the senate thinks they're
[ __ ] important
this is really stupid it's really
[ __ ] stupid that the senate thinks
they're so [ __ ] important
as if katangi brown jackson is not going
to be supreme court justice get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ] why do you
think that mitch mcconnell blocked
merrick garland for almost a year
because he knew if he gave merrick
garland any kind of lie today he would
be a supreme court justice
this is not complicated it's all [ __ ]
it's all smoke and mirrors
and and and because it's all smoke and
mirrors that's why the republican party
picks [ __ ] [ __ ] to be their
nominees
bigots
racist
sexual abusers [ __ ]
fascists that's why they select these
people to be the supreme court traitors
i mean you know clarence thomas's wife
is a traitor
you know but if you get you know
if you eat dinner with a with a if
you're
at a table with 10 nazis and you're
eating dinner with 10 nazis and you're
the 11th person that you're a [ __ ]
nazi
but that would provide us a way of
getting away from the political court
which would give us a better court a
more progressive court a more empathetic
court a court that actually believes
that the american people think that the
constitution is a living document
that we should progress we should get
better
that's what that would deliver now
that's just my [ __ ] opinion
but the good part is i'm not up i'm not
up for
i'm not up for no judge seat never will
be never have been never could be
so i get to give my commentary so pack
that [ __ ] that's the way i see
it okay let's see what's this oh this is
the uh
and that's the response to josh hawley
uh
here is here is the
guantanamo bay
um
explanation that's kind of a long clip
oh wait a second is this her going after
grassley let's do this one oh baby this
is the one i want we're 37 minutes into
the second hour and
amy says grassley asked about cameras in
the scotus courtroom
uh jackson says i would want to discuss
with other justices let's
let's hear
you see the difference in the questions
like brett kavanaugh has to be asked
were you at the party where she was
sexually assaulted
were you at that party
brett
i i like beer and i still drink beer and
i love beer
i may have been drinking beer oh i can't
remember in my calendar it's smart
because i mark everything my calendar i
drink beer
i'm brett kavanaugh he really he really
did maybe rittenhouse got his cue
from um from brett kavanaugh i don't
know
you know this fake ass crying [ __ ] um
but but listen to this riveting question
that uh this wrinkly old republican nut
sack here asked
judge brown jackson this important
riveting question let's hear
i favor allowing supreme court hearings
to be televised yeah okay what's your
view on this how would you feel about
cameras in the courtroom yeah which
about 40 50 or or 40 or 45 of our
students allow
well senator i would want to
discuss with the other justices
their views and and understand
all of the various um
potential issues related right
cameras in the courtroom before i took a
position on it
i think that's a fair answer at this
point
oh thank god thank god chuck grassley is
there in the senate judiciary committee
to ask that most important question of
what katangi brown jackson's opinion is
about cameras in a courtroom
what the actual [ __ ]
again
anyone who is out there telling you that
there's no difference in the party this
question is a prime [ __ ] example
it's a prime example where you have to
ask amy coney barrett
are you hiding your bigotry behind your
religion
because it really seems like in your
your your decisions and your your public
writings you're hiding your bigotry and
the way you want to take away liberty
especially from women
from you're hiding it behind your
religion
and you have to ask brett kavanaugh did
you sexually assault this woman
at this party in college
like that's the questions you got to ask
them the question that chuck grassley
has to ask
judge brown jackson is should there be
cameras
should there be cameras
in the in the courtroom judge brown
jackson
and she's like you dumb motherfu is that
really a question
i i i had notes i had notes here that
you were gonna ask some stupid questions
but i did not have that as one of the
notes it's kind of in that kind of the
feeling you got from her is like are you
[ __ ] serious this is a question
rather there's cameras in the courtrooms
oh [ __ ]
this is the difference in the parties
folks
uh let's see here oh here we go here we
go here's lindsey graham
oh baby we're getting to the lindsey
graham part of the thread they're 40
we're 41 minutes into the second hour
here
here's here's it we're get uh the best
part of the thread
the lady g part of the thread are you
guys ready we're gonna we're gonna roast
we're gonna roast lindsey graham here
let's do it
thank you uh judge
yeah again congratulations i want to
talk to you a little bit about family
and faith because in your opening
statement and the people who
introduced you to the committee uh there
was very glowing praise of you as a
person a good friend
you have a wonderful family you should
be proud and your faith matters to you
what faith are you by the way
senator i am um
protestant let's skip over very
important
um but as you know and we've already
seen part of this club no religious
tests in the constitution under under
article 6 and there will be none with me
and
so if there's none with you lindsay why
in the [ __ ] are you bringing it up why
are you bringing up a religious test
look at his face here
lindsey graham's little face here
lindsey graham if if religion isn't such
a big deal lindsay why in the [ __ ] are
you bringing it up in the first place i
bet i bet he can't help but say
why he thinks the religious test is so
important for him to complain about
um
it's very important to set aside one's
personal views yeah about things
in the role of a judge i couldn't agree
with you more and i believe you can
so uh on a scale of one i believe you
can maybe you can't but you should you
can i mean you know it's kind of
optional right with lindsey graham and
these republicans these gqp fascists 10
how faithful would you say you are
what the [ __ ] does that mean by the way
on a scale 1 to 10 how faithful do you
think you are
what the hell kind of [ __ ] is that
i'm an atheist so does that make me a
zero
what the [ __ ] does that mean i don't i
don't do do people do people judge their
own faith on a scale of one to ten
i've never been asked that in my entire
[ __ ] life
i i know where he's going with this
though he's going with this to white
people are mistreated you're we're not
gonna mistreat you katangi brown jackson
because you're a black woman because we
can't get away with that once us white
republicans can't get away with being
racist towards a black woman they'll
call us out on it
but but white people like brett
kavanaugh and amy coney bear oh they're
attacked they're attacked for their
faith that's what he's getting at here
but let's listen it's a religion you
know i go to church probably three times
a year so that speaks poorly of me
who attend church regularly well senator
i am reluctant to talk about my
faith in this way just because i want to
be
mindful
of the need for the public to
have confidence in my ability to
separate out my personal views how would
you feel if a senator up here said
your faith a dogma lives loudly within
you and that's of concern
how yeah that that that senator was
asking amy coney barrett
about
her hiding her bigotry behind her
[ __ ] religion
is what
oh well the reason why i'm a bigot is
because i'm a religious person
god says the bible says
that's why i'm a bigot the reason why i
hate women is because i'm religious get
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
lindsey graham
who gives a flying [ __ ] how religious
judge
brown jackson is no one gives a [ __ ]
the only reason why you give a [ __ ]
whether she's religious or not is so you
can whine and complain about how white
people get treated unfairly in the
senate judiciary committee when
democrats ask them about their bigotry
that is hidden behind religious dogma
[ __ ] [ __ ] would you feel if somebody
up here yeah or something
on our side you attend church too much
for me or your faith is a little bit
different to me
and they would suggest that it would
affect your decision
would you find that offensive
senator i'm i'm i would if i were you
i found it offensive when they said
about judge barrett
is he asking the questions and answering
the questions for her did you notice
that you know
black women have to do this [ __ ] all the
time when they have a [ __ ] white man
they ask him the [ __ ] question and
then they answer their [ __ ] question
for them what the [ __ ] women deal with
this in any way you know
black women especially
what a [ __ ] idiot ask her a question
she can't answer so he answers it for
her the reason i ask these questions is
i have no doubt that your faith is
important to you and i have zero doubt
that you can adjudicate people's cases
fairly if they're an atheist then why
the [ __ ] are you asking
if you have no doubt in your mind if her
religious affiliation is not going to
get in the way
of her making decisions why
in the [ __ ]
why in the [ __ ]
are you asking oh that's right because
you want to complain about how white
people are treated let's listen
if i had any doubt i would i would say
so yeah the only reason i mentioned this
the only reason you're reluctant to talk
about it because it's uncomfortable just
imagine what would happen if people
on late night television called you an f
nut
you're a [ __ ] nut she's not a [ __ ]
nut it's hard to call
judge brown jackson a [ __ ] nut
because she's not one see that's the
other difference here is
a democratic president like joe biden or
barack obama for that matter
picks judges who aren't
[ __ ] nut jobs they're not [ __ ] nut
jobs
they're not religious [ __ ] nut jobs
lindsay that's why the late night tv
host don't call judge brown jackson a
religious nut job because she's not
she's not
speaking in tongues because she
practiced the catholic faith in a way
they
couldn't relate to or found
uncomfortable so judge you should be
proud of your faith i am convinced that
whatever faith you have and how often
did you see watch watch when he says
this watch when he says this watch your
eyes watch your eyes you're reluctant to
talk about it because it's uncomfortable
watch your eyes here just imagine what
would happen if people
on late night television called you an f
nut
speaking in tongues because you
practiced the catholic faith in a way
they uh pay attention to your eyes
uncomfortable
so judge you should be proud of your
faith i am convinced that whatever faith
you have and
[Laughter]
she's like i'm this [ __ ] guy
this [ __ ] guy
this [ __ ] guy
okay here's here's part two of lindsey
graham being a mess that amy has um
maybe this is the uh
the part where he's uh railing on uh
here's a couple parts let's let's listen
uh to this we're 40 48 minutes into the
second hour let's listen to this
lindsey graham meltdown oh you wouldn't
say that you're an activist judge
i would not say that okay
and so we'll have a 20 minutes more
later on but here's what i would say
that every group that wants to pack the
court
that believes this court is a bunch of
right-wing nuts they're going to destroy
they are they are lindsay they're a
bunch of right-wing nut jobs
they're a bunch of right-wing nut jobs
and your party your fascist party is
responsible for making sure that the
federal society places those right-wing
nut jobs those fascist [ __ ] on our
court
so that they can impose their personal
opinions on the rest of america and take
away the liberties of americans
and people in america
whether they're citizens or not that's
that's what you've done
that they're right-wing nut jobs on the
court that are intentionally taking away
liberties away from americans
rory america
that considered the constitution trash
all wanted you picked
and this is all i can say
is the fact that so many of these
left-wing radical groups that would
destroy the law as we know it declared
war on michelle chiles and supported you
is problematic for me
so lindsey graham is upset that he
didn't get his nominee right
this is this is the case so lindsey
graham trashes joe biden trashes joe
biden trashes joe biden
he sides with jim clyburn on the pick
from north carolina and he doesn't get
his [ __ ] way and he's pissed
thank you
thank you senator graham let me mention
uh a few points here uh congressman jim
clyburn was a strong supporter of
michelle childs and now i believe he is
publicly supporting your nomination oops
and michelle childs has been nominated
by president biden oh really circuit
judge oh considered by this committee as
quickly as possible oh so she'll have
her day in front of the committee where
lindsey graham can ask childs questions
about being a federal judge you dumb
[ __ ]
i love about
durban here just stuffed lindsey graham
and a locker on the issue of guantanamo
there are currently 39 guantanamo
detainees okay let's go to one more clip
one more clip of
of lindsay um this is where he throws a
temper tantrum and he walks out of the
room i believe this is it here he gets
really pissed off and he walks out of
the room he's so pissed off let's watch
this testing this system has failed
miserably and advocates to change this
system like she was in
was was advocating would destroy our
ability to protect this country we're at
war we're not fighting a crime this is
not some passage of time event as long
as they're dangerous i hope they all die
in jail if they're going to go back and
kill americans it won't bother me one
bit if 39 of them die in prison that's a
better outcome than letting them go and
if it costs 500 million to keep them in
jail keep them in jail because they're
going to go back to the fight look at
the freaking afghan government it's made
up of former detainees at gitmo this
whole
thing by the left about this war ain't
working
let me also note that larry thompson who
served as deputy attorney general and
president
dick durbin doesn't miss a beat as
lindsey graham gets all butt hurt and
and and leaves the uh the room there um
look this is this is typical [ __ ] yeah i
think i think robin said it earlier here
in the chat that this is all this is all
[ __ ] just for [ __ ] fox news clips all
right this is 30 second fox news clips
that they want to create for sean
hannity and tucker carlson's show to
make themselves feel [ __ ] tough that
way they can get on [ __ ] fox news
tonight
and and pied piper to the [ __ ]
traitors out there in america
all the [ __ ] trump humping traders
out there in america
when he's talking about gitmo detainees
i hoping that they die there
well uh senator lindsey graham
if the america doesn't wake up and see
its sense of humanity with those
prisoners of war as you call them
instead of criminals if we don't wake up
and and see our sense of humanity they
may die there dummy
and by the way
by the way
the [ __ ] detainees again the reason
why some of the detainees are in the
afghan government and nothing to do
with joe biden are the democrats or
katangi brown jackson you dumb
[ __ ]
the reason why
the reason why the one person the one
administration that's responsible for
these former detainees at gitmo to be in
the afghan government to be officials in
the current afghan government
is a trump administration
who set out to make a deal with the
taliban so that they could take over
afghanistan when the exit happened
which was the the [ __ ] exit plan that
joe biden executed
for trump after he lost
in the trump administration's
the trump administration's
desire
to be the ones who were called
oh
we're the ones who shut down the afghan
war it was us
it was our plan
that was a whole point in the first
place is to get that plan done before
joe biden was sworn in
to lock that plan in place to make sure
that the taliban took over the
afghanistan country
they thought that it would be a
successful takeover
that's that's what they thought that way
donald trump and his [ __ ] his [ __ ]
allies could take credit for the plan
that they instituted for afghanistan if
it went well
if joe biden did what he was supposed to
do
and executed the plan well which
for the circumstances the bite
administration did
under the circumstances that trump and
the trump administration left him
but it was trump's plan
for these gitmo detainees to take over
afghanistan lindsey graham you dumb
[ __ ] and you complained all
[ __ ] year last year about the exit of
afghanistan and blamed it on joe biden
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
this is typical [ __ ] republican
double talk
where they're on two sides of the same
[ __ ] issue
and blaming blaming anything that has to
do with the exit of afghanistan our
detainees at gitmo
on katangi brown jackson is really
telling
it's really telling
it really is lindsay
lady g uh thank you mj for the for the
super chat
it's for the uh lady g's little tantrum
we appreciate the super chat remember
you guys if you're on youtube you can uh
buy super stickers you can do super chat
here on youtube we appreciate that uh
rofency says nailed it i think you're
talking about the uh the rant they're on
afghanistan
the rant there on afghanistan
we are 56 minutes into the second hour i
appreciate you guys joining us
here today on the tony michaels podcast
again every single weekday noon eastern
11 central right here on youtube twitter
twitch and now on the midas touch
facebook page so you can join us on
facebook youtube twitter twitch so don't
forget to like and subscribe at all
those places
now look at our new this is our new like
animation boom thumbs up
give us a like either on facebook
youtube twitter twitch wherever you're
at i don't think you can actually do a
thumbs up on twitch can you i don't know
i'm not sure i'm not sure but we have
listeners in all four places
i'm glad you guys join us in those four
places on social media
um also uh don't don't forget that this
week we're gonna have an interview with
bad brad berkwith
we're going to talk about his his dad
there's a clip of his dad that is
[ __ ] fantastic it's actually in the
movie milk
uh bad brad's dad
is in the movie milk if you remember the
movie so we're going to talk about that
in the interview it's a really good
interview and and brad actually
interviewed gabe
you guys love gabe the executive
producer and co-host here at the tony
michaels podcast follow gabe
and i am gabe sanchez on all the social
media also follow us at tonymichaelspot
and you can follow me at the
tonymichaels on all the social medias
but uh brad actually interviewed gabe
that's over on youtube as well that's on
brad's
youtube page
he interviewed gabe
uh i think it was over the weekend and
he posted it over the weekend there's a
lot of stuff even in the interview that
i didn't know about gabe so if you guys
want to learn more about gabe uh brad
does some great 360 interviews we talk
about that a little bit in in the
interview that we do with him uh this
week so go check that out over on brad's
youtube channel the interview that he
had with gabe sanchez
our executive producer and co-host here
on the tony michaels podcast and don't
forget to join us for the rest of the
week every single day wednesday thursday
friday
noon eastern 11 central
youtube twitter twitch
again we're gonna have the bonehead of
the week poll we're probably gonna wait
a little bit though um we used to do it
like when tuesday or wednesday
we've been waiting a little later in the
week now because
these boneheads just pop up it's like
whack-a-mole with these boneheads like
um we'll put three boneheads on that are
trending
yeah tuesday a wednesday afternoon on
twitter by thursday [ __ ] we forgot why
the hell they were trending as boneheads
in the first place
i don't know if you guys have watched
bonehead but every once in a while we're
trying to figure out like live right
there in there like why did we why did
we put this person on bonehead
why did they win
why did they win bonehead of the week
what is going on here
so all the people over on facebook
if you want to get your vote in on bone
head of the week make sure to go to at
tony michael's pod
on twitter that's where we post the
bonehead of the week poll
that's where we post the poll for
bonehead of the week so you get to vote
your voice is heard here we're
pro-democracy right
we're pro-democracy we're trying to
practice how to vote here on the tony
michaels broadcast so we do that with
the moon end of the week poll every
single week
again thank you for joining us here
today and if there's any new listeners
out there again you can download the
podcast
on all the directories even your
favorite boycotted ones spotify apple
google
just go to thetonymichaels.com the link
is in the bio
or you can go to
podcast.dtonymichaels.com or you can
just search the tony michaels podcast on
all your favorite directories
but again go to thetonymichaels.com
follow us there download all the
podcasts there go back and give us a
five star rating if you haven't already
if you're a new listener and you like
the show and you want to continue to to
keep the show going go give us a five
star rating over on your favorite
directory as well
and again tomorrow we will surf the tree
tree
jeez trendy trends and tweety tweets i
guess it's been a long show huh
tomorrow we research noon eastern 11
central join us tomorrow youtube twitter
twitch and now on the mind as touch
facebook page until tomorrow at noon
eastern
surf's up [ __ ] surfs the [ __ ]
up
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking